こんばんわはじめチャツネこんばんわはじめ社長です
あんまり猫いうこと動画言っちゃうと心配されるって言ってないんですけどあのう
すげー2位なら今世紀最大の2位だこういうことはあんまり言いたくないんですけども
たぶん僕の家
取り憑かれてます
嬉しそうな顔するんじゃないあのけっこうこれ新病性が高い話でどこがプレイつか出て
いるかといいますとこちらのいつも動画とくる撮影ビアでございます
やばいかなりヤバいと思ってその僕自身米韓が内部で何とも言えないんですけども入っ
た瞬間の気持ち悪い感じはなんかわかるんですよ
で撲滅結構いろんな友達とか後輩が入ってくるんでケッ
こうな人があの部屋やばいよとあの部屋なんかいるよということをかなりの確率で言っ
てくるんですよ
聞いてみようかまずらしい
でおつかれっすお疲れ様ですねあのさーん
多いランチのさーん
初えび屋ってさぁ
呪われている雪あるー
いやーちょっとあるか欲しいななんかねえ
ます空気違うよっ
ソウル叢書なんだろまあ場所的にはそうかもしれないけど
まあ中
よくないってよというわけですね入ったときの感覚が他の部屋だ違うんですよね僕の
後輩の妹がすごいデー感持っていますけど僕んちに来なくても動画御所で集めさんとの
撮影はやばいよみたいな事言ってるんだけどそれとも聞いてみましょうん
[音楽]
バイトバイトだか空知もタントラチームいっか言ってたんですよね
なんかこのに入って蹴られてるんですよ抜きを一切失うみたいな
バイト育ちバイトバイトかまずバイトしてるのか
正木言ってたから柵木向いてる気がするなぁ
もし欲しい明けましておめでとうございます
めでとうございますねちょっとの一つ聞きたいことがあるんだけどさーん
オイラん家のさーん撮影でやってる3億の
あそこって車呪われてる切ない築港
ある
アルション
年か心当たりありますちなみに来られたらいいなぁ
[音楽]
行った時めっちゃなんか頭痛くなったマジ
結構いろんな人がいるんですけどそれを選ぶ
なかったかこれ本当に何でもやらせじゃありません全くこちらから何も言ってないのに
2人もあたら2人もなんですけどもう全員がですね割とこの撮影に入ると曲はヤバイっ
ていう空気を感じるんですよ僕は出たらないしね逆にこの部屋なんか
すっとするんですよ心が洗われる感じになっちゃってて物件何も感じないんですけども
基本的にある
んだヤバイ感じがするし頭痛くなるとか入り食べないとかそういうことを言っちゃう
ぐらいちょっとヤバい状態ポイント割れチョコ待ってます
一回入ってみますかいやなんだね部屋の一番が4くらいみたいなんですよ入ってみます
[音楽]
[拍手]
あーあー寒い鳥肌が取り方がヤバイわかるかな
とり方が飛ばないんですよパッと見そんなにれんなところないんですけど
ん
ポッ
tue
やばい人助け空も悪いんで尿と何とかしなきゃと思っておりますでなんかあたりで心霊
探知機ってなんか大丈夫かこれは ud を探すことのできるアプリがあったので
ちょっとこれを使ってみましょう
神霊教徒っていうのがてるんですけどバスによって変わるということでございますこの
部屋は602ですねええこわいよー
この部屋を抱いた600なんですけども
骨の部屋はどれぐらいなのかちょっとひとまず除霊もできるの
樹齢ボタンあるよ
あのーホントちょっとこういうな男はいえ部屋で一人でるの考察だから待機等圧呼ぶん
ですよさっき毎晩のように到達という字をしててしっとりでいるの強すぎて部屋に一人
でいたくないですよ
これもうこんな鳥肌立ってますからねアプリでできるのかあんまりでできれば馬鹿な人
はちょっとぞ例だけあってありますでは
行ってきます入ったときのこの心霊の強度に注目ですいきます
ん
上がってるは上がっている上がってるよ
良いことは閉めてみようか
うわぁやまってマジでくれますよもう慣れてきそうなんだけど
うわぁやばいまじやばいまじば今じゃあ大丈夫だこれはっぴーってバッハピッタンマっ
てぴょんっは待ってマジでヤバい
どうなってんだこれはっ on me にょ9やっぱ一番待って待って待って待ちで
by ドスドスどうぞ本当にこの家どうなってるぞれ除霊しなきゃー
ぞれぞれにします
ああ
ああああああああ
[拍手]
相良言えない海はいというわけでこの部屋ちょっとやばいですね
まああたりなんでこれはちょっとしたらただのごまかしにしかしていないかもしれない
んですけど
数字だけじゃなくて実際かなりの人がですねその子の部屋の異常性を訴えているし
ちょっと近いうちにこの辺はなんとかします
わかんないひょっとしたらその例ってあの全部悪い例と限らないじゃないですか
何か良い例もいるし悪いでもいるからちょっとした噂6話
悪いレーダー版一概に悪い例とは言わないんですけどもうちょっとあんまりこれ以上何
かちょっと動かしなことがあったら何とかしようと思っております
除霊の方法とか僕もちょっとよくわからないのでよかったらコメント欄で何かを教えて
ください
ぜひ皆さんちょっとやばいような場所があったら気を付けて下さいじゃあ
レイドヒカキンさんの写真だけど外しておこう
[音楽]
ん
def
ni